dune and the wheel of time are some of
the most beloved series in fantasy and
science fiction it is kind of a strange
coincidence that they both happen to be
getting major adaptations around the
same time of course the wheel of time is
going to prime video thank you jeff
bezos dune is being made into a movie of
warner brothers pitting these two series
together is an unfair thing i truly
think and i don't want to be starting
some kind of feud or war this is an
interesting thought experiment for me to
explore the differences between these
two series now i'm going to be limiting
this video to just the original dune in
the series and the first wheel of time
book the eye of the world and i want to
explore how the writing styles differ
and how
both robert jordan and frank herbert
used their opening novels to set the
stage for the series i will be covering
writing styles character work
and the world building but before i get
into the main subjects both the original
dune and the eye of the world in many
ways subvert expectations for their
respective genres frank herbert really
throws the reader headfirst into this
world while we do have paul it's still
extremely alien it's still extremely odd
and paul is not our only point of view
but i will get into that later because
it's really an omniscient uh narrator
and omniscient perspective whereas the
first book in the wheel of time i'm not
speaking for the whole series but the
first it is primarily from rand's point
of view there are a few other povs but
they're very
short both books
are
trying to subvert
tropes the first books in the series in
these two series are the most
i wouldn't say formulaic but most
familiar you read dune messiah and the
entire mythology the entire like moral
of the story in some ways and dune is
deconstructed carrying on from the point
about writing styles dune is again
written from that third-person person
omniscient
uh point of view we are jumping around
into people's heads sometimes
conversation you know often mid
conversation so there's not a lot of
hidden information there is suspense and
there are things hidden from us
occasionally but for the most part we
know where the players are using that
point of view isn't the best for maybe a
thriller or a mystery or something but
for what dune is it works perfectly in
my opinion wheel of time is a third
person limited later books it jumps
around more between uh povs but in the
first book is mostly rand's perspective
now on a like sentence by sentence basis
both books are sort of similar i i love
frank herbert's writing style i think
it's extremely effective but i
personally prefer the writing in
the eye of the world i think there's
some really beautiful writing in that
book some would say maybe of too flowery
or excessive i think that in it really
paints such a vivid picture in my head
now in dune there is less in the way of
gorgeous description there is great
description i
um you know there and there are some
beautiful passages but that's not the
the focus
um and that can't be the focus i mean
imagine it's like robert jordan is
testing the waters is easing into the
pool because it's cold and chilly
whereas frank herbert's like just
cannonball right into the right into the
deep end that method of entry into this
series uh informs how the books are
written the characters in dune feel like
pieces in a machine there's so much that
feels inevitable that's going to happen
and i don't really get that sense from
the eye of the world i do have to say i
i feel more humanly attached to the
characters in the wheel of time than i
have in dune dune excels in exploring
those internal those internal conflicts
almost because of that constant moving
around and jumping focus i have less
care for each of them and this is kind
of hard to explain you know they start
out as very
naive in dune so many of the characters
are very wise and have seen a lot on
like a personal level i don't feel like
i i care that much about hanging out
with any of them duncan idaho yeah in
terms of general world building
i do
i have to give this to dune look we're
just talking about the first books we're
talking about dune in the eye of the
world in terms of world building dune
packs a punch so many interesting things
explored in the eye of the world but we
have a lot of the
more traditional fantasy stuff to lean
on
when things are too unfamiliar yeah
having a bit of the comfort of easing
into a world from the point of view of
someone who is very new to it is great i
mean that's why we love portal fantasy
too at least i do dune has a different
approach and that's all good sheer scope
of things and the sheer originality i
have to give this to dune hands down at
the end of this all what does this come
what does it boil down to who has the
who has the final tally there is no
tally this is just a simple compare and
contrast um i love these two books
and i thought this could be an
interesting and interesting topic both
books have their challenges i think and
let me know what you think about these
books try to be as objective as possible
which one do you think is the better
opener to the series anyways thank you
for watching bye
[Music]
you